Okay,
we are live. Hello.
How's it going?
Bit late today. I had a little bit of
client work to catch up on.
And uh
corn is being harvested outside.
I'm gonna miss having all the corn right
next to me, though.
Oh, I've gotten used to it.
All right, so uh here's the plan for
today.
I have uh one thing to work on for a
collaboration that I just figured I may
as well do on stream.
And uh after that, depending how long
that takes, I'm going to work a little
bit on the C++ port.
And uh I'll see if there are any
community PRs to merge and stuff as
well. Then I've got some time off
scheduled for this weekend. So no night
stream.
Well, I don't know. Technically, I might
have some time. We'll see.
But
we're going to start with uh the morning
deadlift that I forgot to
Okay. Welcome. Soy next year. What? Oh
yes. Kvert actually. Yes.
Strength level 99.
Here. I'll prove it real quick.
You probably saw Oh, yeah. You saw the
Runescape post, right?
I don't play anymore because I just do
dev all day.
But, uh, yeah. 20 57
37 mil strength XP, 43 mil ranged,
and where is it? Yeah, 418 chambers.
Uh, where's Tob?
300 Tob. A little bit of hard mode. And
where's challenge mode?
39 CMS.
There you go. And as promised, yeah,
that's basically that's 99 twice
if not for OSRS. I mean, to be fair, I
did kind of get a PhD thesis topic out
of it, right?
I did kind of get a PhD thesis. The
scary thing is that's only one of two
MMOs that I have about the same amount
of time in
the vast vast majority of my gaming
hours is about 4,000 hours in each of
two different MMOs. No, no, Iron Man.
I hate skilling.
I was like moderately okay at nhing as
well.
That game is straight heroin to me
though. Like I cannot download that game
otherwise RL will not like RL will not
succeed.
I don't think anything has ever remotely
gotten me as much as MMOs do. Like any
competitive game is a few weeks at most
like at a time like any comp game. Few
hundred hours of Overwatch, few hundred
hours of League, but it's not remotely
the same as an MMO.
I will say though that we are going to
eventually have, you know, neural MMO 3
is not going to be the last MMO. I am
absolutely going to allow myself to do
neural MMO 4 at some point.
what did Meta Fire AI engineer?
I'm not going to comment on just like
random tech news. I have no idea. Right.
The other MMO. Wow. Nope. Any French
viewers in the audience? Anybody who
know Dophus?
That's the other one.
I would run anywhere from four to eight
accounts at a time on that game.
Basically, tactical fantasy chess on
steroids is an MMO.
It's um ironically not that good of a
game unless you play it on a bunch of
accounts at the same time, but it's kind
of awesome when you do.
So,
oh, we have more questions. Hello, I'm
another student inside of you. Plan to
continue education.
Can you write this user account another
letter of recommendation?
I can't write you a letter of
recommendation if I have not worked with
you. That's not how it works. And you
wouldn't want me to even if I agreed to
because I wouldn't be able to write you
a letter that talks about anything that
you've done whatsoever or any of my
experience with you because I have none.
right. Um, let's go check out
the topic for today.
Oh, I probably didn't update the stream
title. Well, there will be some hardcore
PF optimization later. Uh, anyways,
Uh, that would actually that is actually
something that we're very interested in.
We just haven't happened to get any
client inquiries in that domain yet.
Okay, we can actually we can do
something with this, right?
uh what is the command syntax for this?
It's like it's check out with the commit
number, right?
Or the PR number. I mean,
why do we have 20 notifications in 5
seconds?
Oh, this silly thing.
FPR,
welcome. Yeah, this is it. what I was
looking for.
Okay, we got contrastive.
Let's see what we're supposed to do with
this.
Yeah.
Goal is going to be that we uh basically
we test this out on some environments.
We do a bit of work on this and then uh
I get to spend some time on the C++
and then that's the week.
Oh, and that we get some bench sets in.
Can't forget that.
Every day is bench day.
Eat mind podcast next week and Joe Rogan
the week after.
Um,
who the heck would I like to be on a
podcast with
podcast? Not really.
H
would actually be cool.
Carmarmac would be awesome.
Or actually,
realistically, the one that I could
probably figure out how to arrange would
be uh Rayson.
We're not starting a podcast. I already
stream enough. That's You get enough
puffer content.
I don't know if it's as much that man as
just like he's not used to being in
front of a a camera.
It's weird if you're not used to it. You
know,
it's actually it's a great thing to do
in general if you've got social anxiety
or whatever. It'll get that fixed up
right quick.
Hey Jess, today I am messing with uh
this contrastive loss PR a little bit
and then we're going to get to C++
optim.
Okay, so this doesn't do anything, my
guy.
I'm not attempting to merge this. This
is more of um a collaboration where
somebody made a branch that has a
contrastive loss and wants it tested.
They provide a script of some variety
for this.
doesn't like to learn without search,
but hey.
Right. 1.2 mil.
So, Jess, I think that there's
there's like um a action space pruning
thing going on. You should totally be
able to learn chess.
Like just thinking about it, there's no
way you can't learn chess.
It's like a re It's an annoying obs and
action encoding problem. I'd say I'll be
happy to take a look at it at some point
with you. Maybe even later today once I
do this.
I don't really have to make more C++
progress today. I'd be happy to do a
couple community PRs depending or
community like things.
I do need to have this done today
though. This is for a collab.
Did you succeed with the pie packaging?
I believe so.
Go try more tonight. I don't get
anywhere.
Um, yeah.
Yeah, I'll take a look at it though.
Just like chess is going to be a really
really cool end.
I totally believe that you can get like
a bot that's better than me as well. I'm
not good at chess.
If you get a bot that you can just train
in a few minutes that's better than me,
that'll already be so cool.
I don't think you need that, man. What
are you doing with the obs? Like the
most basic thing I would do with the obs
would just be like one hot all the
pieces and then you have um
how many piece types are there? There is
like
is it like eight pieces or it's like
wait pawn uh king queen
rook bishop knight is it seven types.
So uh and then two colors. So, it's
going to be 8x 8x4 obs.
I totally believe that if you have a
like that with a reasonable architecture
versus a one-step look ahead opponent,
you can train something that'll beat
that very quickly.
Small models are possible to run. Uh,
inference on a Raspberry Pi is totally
doable. I don't know how fast those are
for training. That'll probably suck. It
might be faster than SP3 with a GPU,
which is funny. But it's still not going
to be super fast.
If it's like just a low-end CPU,
presumably you can get, I don't know,
somewhere between 10 and 50,000 steps
per second training for very simple ends
with no GPU.
But you can definitely deploy small
models on a Raspberry Pi, no problem.
Hold the C++.
The C++ branch is a mess though, dude.
Yeah, it should be able to go up quite a
bit though.
If you just calc flops, you should be
able to go up quite a bit. Uh the next
thing is going to be for me is going to
be porting the optimizer.
Uh the optimizer has to get ported to C
because I don't you can't pass it a
Python optimizer. I think you might be
able to make some of the optimizers from
C++ though. So we'll see.
Welcome everyone on YouTube. Uh so what
we're doing today here is first I am
messing with this contrastive loss PR
and we're seeing if we can get this to
do anything and then after that uh I'm
going to be back to working on the C++
port of Puffer Lib and Perf
optimizations there.
And then if you have questions or things
uh if you're looking to get started with
Puffer over the weekend, ask today
because I'm not going to be streaming
tomorrow. I'm taking some time off this
weekend.
It's been pretty much like three weeks
straight of just grinding, grinding,
grinding on this.
Yes. So somehow the per uh the profiling
is like broken or whatever.
Looks like a small bug. Yeah, I've been
at the farm 3 weeks.
Haven't gotten a lot done in that time,
right?
Don't know what's happened to my
dashboard, but
probably this chunk of logic got messed
up somehow in this PR.
You move
farm. Well, Connecticut is was where I
grew up. I mean, I went out to undergrad
in California,
right? And then I did grad in Boston.
stuck.
Um,
Yeah. 4090.
The farm is Maryland. Yep.
Not really.
There's not really a family. It's my
family just got a farm
and I went, "Oh, cool. That sounds
peaceful.
Let me uh
let's put some servers and some gym
equipment.
There's a new course record as well for
the um the farm run today. Just the
trail that I do around here is 5.7
miles. Uh hard trail, like really like
soft ground, gives under your feet a
lot. Running through tall grass as well.
Uh it is
827 pace per mile
down from the previous was 9 like 9:06
or something 9:03 something like that.
Felt good today.
uh just temperature.
Hang on.
5 1 0
Bullish on founders that run and lift
hard. You missed the uh the morning
deadlift already.
The morning deadlift bar is up to 365.
My best pull was 410 for two, but that
was with belt and straps and also
substantially heavier than I am now. So,
we're going to see if I can get back to
uh four plates, but with no belt, no
straps, just chalk.
Yeah, you also get to hear the servers
just but other than that, it's quite
peaceful. Hello, Amed.
Wait, did you live stream your polls?
You know what, Mark? Here you go. Just
for you.
Multi-threading.
Uh multi-threading actually might be
legitimately helpful to us with the
infrastructure.
Yeah. So fairly easy 365. I figure
my max is probably
probably like just under 400 depending.
So we're going to get to a comfortable
four plate. That's the goal. like a
comfortable just pull it whenever
foreplay plate would be good. And then I
won't have to actually feel like I need
to max it. I'll just do uh we'll have
like the comfortable max, right? Which
is more likely a kind of like a five rep
max.
Creatine will get you there. I ordered
some creatine. I don't take any. We'll
see if the new stuff doesn't bother my
stomach.
I honestly don't even really know if
I'll like it that much. I didn't get it
for the fitness. I got it because
apparently it's good for cognitive
stuff. Um because on the fitness side,
it also kind of makes you just carry a
couple extra well more than a couple
extra pounds of water weight, which
isn't great. That kind of just sucks
overall. So, we'll see how that feels.
If it's enough of an energy boost though
that carrying the extra few pounds uh
like doesn't hurt my running, then I'll
be fine with it.
Because you know, you have to carry all
that extra water for 5.7 miles of every
morning over trails.
lightweight. You know, Mark, the thing I
really miss is being able to overhead
press. I hurt my shoulder and uh it's
the one thing that just refuses to fix
itself. I might have to go get like some
shock therapy or something cuz I can't
press I can't press more than like a 100
pounds straight up even on a machine
without the shoulder buckling.
I could technically train one shoulder,
I guess, but that kind of sucks. I don't
know what to do about that.
Um,
I figure eventually I'll just get to a
training block where the objective of my
next training block is fix my shoulders
and I'll just dedicate time to it cuz
I'm kind of doing a million things right
now, right? Like outside of all the work
I actually do, I've got the morning
running training. I've got the uh the
current like
the deadlift goal plus the just like
general muscle building training,
bodybuilding style training, trying to
put on lean muscle cuz I lost a lot of
weight. Um and then I've got the
flexibility training I do in the
evenings. I already have quite a bit of
training doing.
Did you do any kinesiology?
Well, I'd have to know what that field
is in order to Is that the uh like study
of muscles and how they behave?
Well, I can spell it.
Oh, yeah. No, not at all.
You heard it lifting. Yeah, Mark. Cuz so
somebody distracted me on a dumbbell
press. Basically,
it wasn't fun
and it seemed like a really minor injury
at the time, but it just refused to
heal.
a shoulder problem. Started sleeping on
my back and it fixed it. Really?
That's tough.
I had a decent enough overhead as well.
like uh I had a 165 strict overhead
press.
Um that was my best and I was like I had
a pretty solid training program and I
was trying to go for a body weight
strict press
or like maybe like a 200lb push press
and it hurt my shoulder.
Tear wasn't getting better. Yeah, I
probably just have some sort of small
tear. I figure I need to just do more
accessory as well, like do face pulls,
you know, kind of just like all sorts of
light pulls from different angles and
I'll probably be able to start training
it as long as I ease into it. 10
sessions of fizz. Yeah, I mean that's
probably true as well.
This is what was solved it.
Well, Mark, like I tried sleeping on my
other shoulder and it didn't fix this
one. So,
I don't have bands, but I have um I mean
I have this whole I actually I really
love this cable machine. It was the
cheapest thing that I got in the uh the
new batch of equipment and it's been the
thing I've used by far the most. This
like dual stack cable tower. I got that
whole thing for less than two grand.
Nautilus dual stack. 240 pound. 240
pounds per stack.
I know what servers cost and servers
cost way more than that.
So,
yay. Equipment.
We're going to get this sweep running
and then I'm going to do a couple bench
sets
and then um we're going to hopefully do
some C++.
I kind of hope they don't finish cutting
all the corn today.
If they cut all the corn, there's
nothing to like wave in the wind.
It's peaceful.
Come on. Machine should be back up by
now.
Give it a minute.
Um, I need to buy some more at some
point, Mark.
I do need to buy some more
server interest rates. I'm not buying
them on credit.
I just buy them straight out in cash.
When I said before that all of these
were paid off, like I bought them before
with my own cash and then, you know, the
company turned out enough revenue to
like fully pay off the investment is
what I meant.
these ones. We've got, I think, eight
boxes, which are just uh like top- end
desktops. Well, for the time, top- end
desktops with 4090s in them. Um, and
then we've got there's one box with a
5090, which is probably the spec I would
use for new ones with AMD chips, uh, AMD
like CPUs and 5090s. And then I've got
two tiny boxes that have 6490s each. So
Puffer's got like 20 22 GPUs total.
Yeah,
you buy them new, ever consider used?
You don't you can't like bulk buy top
end used desktops. Um, and if they're
three years old used, then they're
basically useless anyways.
I've had honestly I've had enough
problems with these that like I don't
want to save the money at this point. I
just want to pay and I want to have the
thing not ever have any problems because
these ones they sent to me the Intel
chips have just given me non-stop
problems. I'm never buying another Intel
chip ever. Like [ __ ] Intel. I was I
bought Intel everything forever and they
shipped two consecutive generations of
faulty chips somehow. So, no more Intel
chips. Uh, and then also these ones,
this one's on Main Gear. The fans that
they sent were super cheap, and I can
hear them rattling now, and it's super
obnoxious.
Um, so like every time I noticed these
rattling, I kind of remember, okay, they
sent me shitty fans. So, uh, the next
ones I would buy would be they'd be AMD
CPUs, uh, 5090s, and Noctua fans for
sure.
buy from Dell. Nope. Dell doesn't make
this type of crap, I don't think. Like
you go to gaming desktop companies. I
got these from Main Gear.
see. Convert. I might actually be able
to help you with this.
Uh, but I'm going to need you to post
the link again in a second. Can you post
the link again, Convert?
Wait, they don't have 128 core thread
rippers, right?
They have 64 core and 108 thread
CPUs, right?
this is good.
Uh yep. Cool.
8 gig kit.
Get yourself a 4TB drive because they're
cheap and you might as well
1,200 watts enough. You might need
1,600.
I think 1 1200 is probably okay, though.
I don't know. Uh yeah, this is basically
my identical build, man. Except we have
9950X. We didn't get the X3DS. I don't
know if there's a difference between
those two honestly for what we do. But
yeah, solid build.
It's actually kind of nice to see all
this on here because then I know the
markup cuz the markups used to be really
low, but actually Oh yeah, here's the
wattage is low. Fine. Yeah, this is
good. Um,
so you add a case into this is four
grand.
So yeah, they started selling them for
like seven grand or whatever, which was
ridiculous. You're missing a few things
on here though, dude. You're missing
You're missing your case fans. Uh that
actually matters. Get knocked to a case
fans. Don't deal with the shitty ones
that just whatever. Um and get yourself
a nice case. Don't try to build it
small.
I think you can do
here.
I mean, this is basically all I did,
right?
Uh, customs.
Where the heck is this?
I think we did.
Yeah, we did the north. So, the latest
ones that I did was this. You just go to
5090.
Your website shouldn't lag when I go to
do this and it shouldn't display me ads.
I present to you
the state of modern web development.
Well, apparently I can't even do it.
So, you can go type that config in here
and see if it works for you.
Modern web development people.
I swear we just need to like burn React
and all the modern frameworks and like
the people who work on these and the
people who use these and like these just
need to know that they are bad
programmers and need to feel bad about
themselves. Like it's just pathetic.
Do you understand how hard it is to make
an application that is laggy? Like with
just like how incredibly fast computers
are versus how stupidly simple these
operations are?
I mean, it's basically like nuking a fly
and missing
is
add block. I don't know. I think I have
a plugin for it.
Samsung.
Yeah, low cost component.
This is basically just lowc cost
component.
All right, this runs.
It's just big tech in general.
It's essentially it's impossible to get
anything done when you're like trying to
work as a team and you have bad people
on the team. That's it's as simple as
that.
It's not even like trying to play soccer
with like a bad person on your team.
It's probably like trying to do uh
It's like probably like playing trying
to play Counter Strike or something. No,
it's even worse than trying to play
Counter-Strike with a bad person on your
team. I can't even think of a team sport
where somebody can sabotage you as badly
as uh just like even a well-intentioned
but really bad programmer can in
software.
Yes, you're completely correct. It's
like League of Legends. Yes, it's
actually that bad. It's like trying to
play League of Legends when somebody is
just running it the [ __ ] down on your
team.
Thank you for that.
I forgot. I don't know why I didn't
think of that. I got uh I got mildly
into League over the summer
because, you know, in California, I
happen to still have a desktop with
Windows on it. This one intentionally
runs Linux, so I can't download League
or Valerant.
So, Valerant's not that dangerous.
League kind of gets me a little bit,
but I'm just too bad at that game to
like get stuck in on it for very long.
MMOs have always been the the heroin.
All right, this is cool, right?
We'll check in on this periodically
throughout the rest of today. But that's
our contrastive stuff set up.
Hate them. Google the least meta the
most.
Who are the least meta the most?
I mean, Meta has the redeeming quality
of PyTorch being like less [ __ ] than the
other stuff out there
off the league. Yeah, I don't have it on
my uh thing. What's your main lux
tried doing I tried playing Trindir. I
thought it would be more uh more
thematically appropriate, but the only
thing I could even like remotely figure
out how to press the buttons on was uh
long range mages.
Anyways,
um
bench set and then we will start on some
actual C++ optim. I will get my next cup
of coffee. So, I will be awake for it as
well and we will continue.
Let's see if I can get 200 on the bar
today.
Hell yes. Oh jeez.
Oops. And I forgot my coffee in the
microwave.
All right. So,
go to this.
C
uh C++
I heated my coffee up. It's not a kettle
either. It's a coffee pot. I made a pot
this morning and it got cold.
We don't use kettles to heat something
up like some type of caveman.
You'll get microwaves installed um in
the UK about the same time you get AC
installed though.
Make sure that our uh
sweep is running.
Okay. So, where we left this off,
have to install this.
I don't think any of this [ __ ] is
documented. So,
we are going to have to do more LM
[ __ ] today, which I hate, but
the least of the evils at this point.
Why do they call it Sarah brass instead
of Cberus?
It just heats the water. You have a
Bluetooth kettle. Nah, my guy. Nah.
I will say if you're going to drink tea,
the Brits are correct that the way to do
it is with milk and sugar. The way to
drink coffee is absolutely black with
nothing in it.
Black coffee, vanilla ice cream, and my
whiskey. Neat.
I should at least go check to see if the
docks are Oops.
Yeah, this is like just shoot super
shitty docs, right?
Okay, it actually does have just Adam
directly.
Black coffee milky tea. Okay, well,
you've redeemed the UK one sanity point.
This doesn't look bad, right?
So, why don't we just do instead of
passing the optimizer,
Don't even consider non-milk slop as
tea.
Uh if you're drinking like ulong tea or
something,
it's actually like there are tees that
are good that way, but British tea with
like British style tea without milk and
sugar is just awful.
I'm getting music for this as well. This
is when I start to cheat and uh not just
do everything
few weeks.
Okay.
Okay. So there we get create
Okay. Okay. So there we get create optimizer, right?
Then we do here's the optimizer is
There.
Deep ocean.
I have another name for that already.
It's Barracuda.
We'll get like a version of the puffer
that's slightly stretched and with one
tooth out like a you know mean
barracuda.
Do you have a CUDA N for testing? Yes, I
do. It's in here. It's just squared, but
it exists.
I will warn you though, it's not going
to get more C++ over time. It's actually
it will be the opposite. So like the
only way that I possibly see this
working right is if I basically I make
it so that writing M's in CUDA is the
same as writing M's in C.
Like
so I don't like don't expect to be doing
fancy C++ fancy CUDA. That's just not
the direction that I'm going to go with
it.
I'm not going to sell uh the simplicity
of Puffer LIIB for a bit of performance.
I'm going to get more performance and
keep it simple
Uh, it's not exactly.
It depends. Um
it what I'm saying here right is that
the CUDA looks a lot like C and if I
decide that we're going to do CUDA ends
it's going to be that the CUDA and C
code is going to be the same. You'll be
able to run it on CPU or GPU.
And then I basically I think I have a
way to do this. I just it's not as clean
as I would like it to be yet
because it relies on a couple of
annoying macros.
Okay. So, where should I free
and close breaks at the end of training?
Yeah, I think I just addressed this
recently.
I'm pretty sure I just like messed with
this.
You can't do it in Close. You have to do
it, I think, in vet close.
Yeah. Oh, I made a shared close here
in uh it's in the multis sweep branch.
You can backport it. You don't have to
go to 40. in multi sweep, but I made a
shared close um and that like vet close
will call this.
Yeah, this is new convert. I didn't have
a way to do this before.
This is actually pretty legitimate work.
This is cool. Good job to him.
the heck is wrong with this?
I actually just Well, it's fine. We'll
just get through it like this. We'll get
through it this way and then um I'm
going to refactor this to not be C++
garbage classes.
Ho ho. There we go, folks. Look at that.
Hell yes.
Kaboom.
Plus
a lot of PF.
That was it.
now. We can improve from here.
This is my This is the desktop that's
also running the stream. This is my 4090
box.
I'm going to commit this right now
because,
you know, why not?
We should be able to get it faster than
this even still.
But this is a very nice start.
Make sure the uh the sweep is still
going.
Our sweep is still going.
And let's go check on
That's not good.
Well, so far no good.
We shall see.
But that is what they asked me to do is
to just like see if this contrasted
thing works.
and probably still get it faster than
this.
I need to wake myself up though. I'm
like tired today. No wonder towards the
end of a 3-week block. And also, I
pushed my morning run like psychotically
hard today. I PRD the course by um
I think like 36 seconds a mile or
something.
I'm get some bench sets in and then um I
think what I'll try to do unless people
have questions because if people want to
get stuff answered, this is going to be
a good time. I'm not going to be
streaming tomorrow. Uh but if we don't
have stuff to look at for the community,
then I will I suppose I'll just try to
clean this thing up and iterate a little
bit and see if I can get the prototype
to be a bit more mature. I'll be back.
All right.
Okay.
If I get three sets in of 200,
be pretty happy today.
That's the ab training.
Find some other stuff to do as well.
3:49. I got a couple hours at least.
See if we can't make some good progress
on this.
This inference is kind of fast.
Oh, this
they have a fun little trick
called chips the size of an iPad.
Sarah Brris's whole thing is wafer
scale, right? They like they're a chip
company and they use the entire wafer
for their chip.
That's why I'm using it. I'm probably
going to get a sub to them as well.
They were kind of like the crazy company
a few years ago, like doing an insane
hardware thing and it actually works.
I wonder if you could make the chips
even bigger than that.
You can't like 3D print a a cube or
whatever that has cooling tubes.
I mean, like you can't like you
obviously can't, but it's cool.
Wafers wafers standard as big. So bigger
is harder to produce. Yeah. Yeah.
Hardware. Cool. That [ __ ] is like
mindbogglingly complicated to think
about, right?
It's cool that we have people though in
that like we have people in all sorts of
different areas just in the chat here,
right?
That's kind of one of the uh the things
I'm hoping, you know, is if I keep doing
the stream thing and I keep doing the
Twitter thing is that eventually we'll
just have technical people in so many
different areas that like, you know,
it's pretty easy to then get information
on hm can we do a like a relatively
small concentrated thing to make a big
advancement in some other area of
science, you know?
Can you please make
a draft PR?
What would it be a PR too?
I would didn't I have to make like some
board because 40 will just become the
new main branch the way we do our
releases. Convert
Do you want like a list of [ __ ] to go
into 40?
Oh, did they have draft? I didn't see
that.
But there you go. There's a PR thing.
Oh, wait. This is C++. We have a two
pass compiler, don't we? Or am I stupid?
Wait, C++ have two pass?
I don't [ __ ] know.
I swear just by default you get like the
most disgusting
why why C++ why why language like this
like there's no good reason to ever do
This
Can I just do this?
There will just not be any, right? If I
can avoid it, I'm just going to put
everything in strrus and tell torch to
go [ __ ] itself as much as possible.
I'm not going to write idiomatic C++ if
it's like if it's just bad, right?
I mean,
we can kind of just say screw it. No.
And just put this down here.
Yeah, pretty effective for beating
somebody over the head. Not much else.
That describes C++.
Yo, can you just use it directly? You
probably can, right?
So yeah, literally this whole code was
just because stupid Python Paul, right?
Memory pinning.
What?
Think about your comment for a second.
The ENV is currently on GPU.
What would you possibly have to pin?
Right.
What would you possibly be pinning?
uh this is a cuda port of an ocean anvil
Ready.
I mean, he's just like, "For [ __ ]
sake, man. Welcome to the dark side.
Memories safe and bunkers fer my kish
ass." How about that?
Like, yay, unique pointers. You solved a
problem that didn't exist until you made
it a problem.
Insert Bane quote.
I went from games modding
to physics 2 at universe. Wait, I went
from games modding as a teen to physics
sims at uni. Insert Bane quote here.
Dude, that's so freaking funny because I
thought of the other Bane.
I thought of this Bane when you said
that.
We can start doing stuff with this now,
right? Like
I think from this we can make progress.
All right. I need a few minutes though.
I use a restroom. I got to get a couple
sets in
and then we will continue on dev
till 6 most likely.
It will be good. will be swell
and I will figure out
um
I think we'll just try to get like most
of the most of the code in place, you
know, like the learning rateuler and all
the things we use. Maybe we'll get a
well maybe we'll get be float 16 as
well. I don't know. I'll be right back.
All right,
three sets of eight,
200 lb.
Uh,
might do a couple more. We'll see. I
really should make it so it's three sets
of flat and three sets of incline, but
little iffy on the shoulder still.
Hang on. I got to go do one thing on
this. I got to go look up one thing and
then we'll get back to Perf
optimization.
And uh
yeah, we keep going.
Okay, this is literally just API docs at
this point. So, I'm happy as long as I'm
just using this for like API docs and
I'm not like just copy pasting [ __ ] back
and forth for big segments. I'm happy.
Oh yeah, it got it wrong. Did I just use
this?
Ah, I see. So, it doesn't exist cuz they
write a lot of their crap in um in
Python, I guess.
But it's pretty easy to implement,
right?
You need the base learning rate, don't
you?
Nice.
Right. Look at that.
Now we got ouruler.
Is Quen 3 good? Uh, I don't know. I
don't particularly care. The reason I'm
using this is because it's Sarah Brass
and they're really really fast.
Like this gets served instantly.
I was using gro before which is also
like fine. It's just honestly the thing
that matters the most. I don't I
actually don't usually even bother
thinking at all about the language model
I'm using because I use them so little.
But because I'm stuck dealing with this
like sort of halfdocumented C++ API, um,
this is better. And all I really need is
for this to be like fuzzy documentation
that's served fast and it's perfectly
good for that.
ideas for games that are kind of at the
edge.
Um,
longer form stuff for sure. Like the
stuff that was done in Pokemon for
instance, that's like really long form.
I'd be interested to see how much of
that we get with just speed versus how
much of it needs new algo
um
in context learning. So I had this like
potion like potion crafting environment.
I was thinking of doing in which the
recipes would change every time or the
recipes would change once in a while,
but like you'd have to essentially learn
what the recipes were for this roll out
by trial and error over the course of
making several potions. So like in
context stuff. Um
We definitely need more control things.
There's a guy that was doing double
pendulum. A couple guys actually at this
point. We'd love to have that. Uh let me
think.
There's all sorts of like isolated
things we can do in multi- aent that
would be interesting that deal with
credit assignment. And honestly like a
lot of more dedicated M's towards
testing like different different like
aspects credit assignment um
of I guess for multi- aent we're going
to need more selfplay stuff because
we're working on selfplay. There is a
big PR for Robocode from Tosian that I
never merged. So if anybody wants to
take a look at Tosian's PR on uh Robo
Code, I love that environment and I
would love to see that one finished. Um,
yeah, those are some things at the
moment.
Robocode's actually a really good one to
finish.
Well,
but don't just go from the current code
because Toina actually has a really big
PR to it. So you can go like look at the
current and then look at his PR and go
from There.
genetic end. Someone did today. No.
Did somebody PR a genetic env Oh, wait.
Yes. Yes. That uh that article. Yes, I
saw that. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I thought somebody had gone and like PR
a full a full thing.
Yeah, the moral one that looks like
neural MMO.
Um
yeah, Daniel. So there are M and
typically with collab M there are M's in
which you can collaborate and do better.
Uh but generally you want there to be
something you can learn on your own as
well. That's one more realistic and two
tells you if you actually have your ends
correct. MOA. If you want a hard
environment there where there's obvious
room for collaboration, then it's MOA.
You're going to have to make the enemies
though smarter. So, either selfplay or
just better scripted enemies.
You can also technically learn pack
hunting on Nurmmo.
It's a little tougher.
each side. Kind do robo code. Spencer's
got an N he's working on, but like we
would like to have multiple for this
just like Robo code.
It's not a big project either. Like that
whole M should be sub thousand lines.
It's an awesome awesome environment as
well with a lot of history. Um,
yeah.
I've actually it's been on my want list
for a
How optimized is Retro Gym? Oh boy, this
will be fun. Uh, so Retro Gym is the
worst optimized piece of garbage
imaginable. You can't even run multiple
copies of those environments on the same
thread. Uh or I don't even think on the
same core.
Yeah, it's really really rough.
Uh yeah. So I just right from that
you're screwed.
It's even slower than like normal Atari
M for that reason.
Puffer on the other hand gets you
millions of steps per second. So let's
just say conservatively that Puffer is
Nah, that's underelling puffer a little
bit cuz that's including our training
loop.
Maybe 5 to 10,000 times faster. Puffer
very fast, my friend.
Oh, if it's trading at three steps per
second, then it's then puffer more than
a million times faster, which would be
really funny.
But actually, you can make um you can
get Doom to be pretty fast. Like, you
can get Doom over 100k. I have a little
binding for that.
That's amazing. It's more amazing how
unoptimized the uh the originals were
than anything, frankly. Like, yeah, I
put a lot of work into this, but you
should never be able to make stuff this
much faster. And Puffer is going to get
even quicker with the next update.
What you're watching here is live PF
optimization trying to port chunks of
Puffer Lib to um the Torch C++ API.
The thing that kind of tipped me over
the edge on this was the compile times
thing, right? Like you don't have to
wait for your model to compile like to
jit everything every time if you do
this. Pretty great.
when the vaccine interview drop.
Um, he said in a week or so.
I was falling asleep by the end of it.
Oh, yeah. One fun thing about this. So,
I got my entire camera and audio
settings, like I had to fix everything
with it. I had four different audio
programs and then I finally got it set
up like and then 5 minutes before the
interview I said my camera's just a
little bit dark. It's night. Let me just
increase the brightness. Everything
crashes. Had to take the interview on my
phone. It was great.
But it's a chill interview.
[ __ ] drivers, man. Like
OBS always works by the way. Like this
is just software being [ __ ] because if
everything could just run through Elsa,
we'd be just we'd be set. But no,
instead we have three different audio
layers and only one of them works.
Some of the moral environments you
worked on, one of which was mobileite,
could those be extended to single player
mode? Hang on. singleplayer
mode
Well, John, I guess in my mind, like
in my mind, what's the difference? Cuz
it's not like we have a separate moral
algorithm, right? We just run the same
algorithm anyways.
So, like I I guess I don't see such a
big distinction.
Um
I don't see such a big distinction, I
guess, is what I'm saying. Like
technically,
if you want to run it as a single agent
where like one network controls all five
agents, all you would have to do is like
some reshapes in the observation layer.
I'm pretty sure
I guess I could make it easier to like
use a shared network or whatever.
That could be a thing, I suppose. But I
don't even know if that's going to be
easier. Like
that might actually be hard. It actually
might be harder to learn it um sing like
multi- It might be harder to learn it
single agent versus multi-agent
because in the multi- agent setting,
right, you optimize your own selfish
reward.
I think you basically though you just
treat it as if it were a single agent
environment and you and it's kind of
chill. Oh, and by the way, the the
opponents right now in MOA are
rule-based. I should have clarified.
Like the default opponents are
rule-based. They're just not super
smart. Like somebody could make better
ones.
Uh, wait. We can't do compute pup
advantage like this, can we?
No, we cannot.
I kind of want to just try
before we do that, right?
and I got to run for dinner relatively
soon.
This should give a reasonable speed up.
Like a very reasonable speed up.
This is Adam still. Yeah, we're going to
have to port Muan or just grab the uh
there is a version in Python apparently.
I mean, PyTorch, it's just not into a
full release.
I'm going to go after this. So, um, for
folks watching, all my stuff's at
puffer.io. AI. You want to help me out
for absolutely free, start the GitHub.
Get involved with dev, join Discord. If
you're interested in educational stuff
or my latest research, it's all on X.
I'm taking this weekend off for once and
I will be back early next week.
Nearos symbolic. Um, yeah, if it makes
sense.
Yeah, Kvert did make that end.
This is a cool end.
six 17 million what
limits would be on my hardware with no
Python.
Wait, lib torch.
What do you mean? 17 million SPS of
what? Raining.
Well, okay.
We got it to run. It's slower,
so there's something wrong. But we did
get it to run.
Let me commit this.
Okay, there we go.
And that's a wrap for today. So, thank
you very much, folks. I'll be back early
next week. Uh, we will be probably
working more on getting this to uh
mature implementation. I'm sure that
there's going to be bugs and stuff from
the port. There's going to be clean up.
I don't want this to be like some opaque
garbage implementation. I want this to
be something where you're going to open
it and say, "Oh, that's basically no
harder than the Python." Um,
no training. Okay. Yeah. Error message.
Crucial learn inside.
Yes, you need to learn to read errors.
These error messages kind of just suck,
though. All right. Thanks everyone. Do
start the repo if you haven't already.
It takes like two seconds. It actually
really helps more than you would expect.
Um, and gives me more time to do this
type of dev live instead of doing
advertising and other things in order to
keep the place afloat.